thank
you good morning everybody the sitting
is
opened and the first
item on today's agenda is the sarra vena
report on the sustainable use of plant
protection products and our rapporter
has uh just rushed into the chamber and
I now invite her to take the
floor
yeah good morning good
morning and thank you madam president
and
uh commissioner
sis
colleagues we are finally here and first
of all allow me to thank all of those
who have made it even possible to be
here holding this debate today because
as you know um a Sur vote tomorrow uh is
not something we could have taken for
granted uh
it's an issue um that was subject to
many attempts to block uh we had very
onesided uh provision of information to
put it nicely and um no real support for
our efforts to do something for the
Europeans and their environment so it's
a delight to be here today and um um we
look forward to the vote tomorrow it was
a long
path and that despite the fact that
there is a broad consensus in the
broader population saying yes we want a
drop in the use of pesticides the risk
for the environment for our groundwater
our drinking water our soil um have
become unacceptable almost 82% of those
AR from Denmark Germany Poland Spain
Romania
France have
asked for Change and they are worried
about the environmental impact of
pesticides 67% are worried about their
own health and the health of their
children and grandchildren friends
partners and science supports these
concerns there's a letter signed by
6,000 scientists on on SR and
Nal
and it was a multidisciplinary
approach broad
consensus for the reduction in
pesticides the increasing residues of
pesticides droping insect the effects on
soil and the derivative products which
have not yet been uh investigated are
harmful have become a huge problem for
people animals and our
environment
if you go and do um your cleaning today
at home and collect dust from your
bedroom I'm sure that uh you can
guarantee that there'll be pesticide
content in uh in that household dust but
it's in our blood it's in our uteruses
um there are more than a thousand
environmental toxins and we now need to
seriously take on the task of reducing
that the long-term consequences for
health by
biodiversity and our ecosystems as well
as our natural resources is something
that we need to stand up for now because
we have a responsibility not just for
our neighbors but for our children
future
Generations our grandchildren and their
children but we have a problem as well
that of protecting food
security
so we need to ensure that our um food
security is protected that biodiversity
is
protected and we don't want to threaten
those what we've been done what we've
been doing so far is a real threat to
our food security and the Very basis of
our
existence and it's not the
to that is responsible for that studies
show that overuse of pesticides are um
senseless they cost more than um they
bring in in profit the
European uh proposal European commission
proposal for a toolkit uh relating to
the use of pesticides and its
reduction not only saves poisons in our
environment but it
also leads to increased revenues and
that's something where we would expect
to see
Farmers welcome uh this to call for it
with saying we're doing something for
society and our own financial situation
oh I've run out of time so um I ask you
to vote tomorrow for a strong sir so
that we can respond to the wishes of
Europeans thank you very
[Applause]
much thank you very much raor and now
we're going to hear from from Clara
Aguilera who's responsible for the
agriculture committee's
opinion
much thank you very much
president commissioner I should like to
begin by thanking all of the Shadow
reporters and the technical team from
the agre committee for all of the work
that was carried out in this committee
we just heard from the raor from the
Envy committee M Vayner and I recognize
the fact that the report that has been
presented here to the
it it actually made the commission's
proposal more stringent now that is not
just my opinion what we can see is that
this proposal continues to be an issue
for European farming as the agre
committee has
stated indeed we saw that there was a
rejection of this now I will continue to
reiterate the point yes we agree with a
reduction in the use of plant protection
products over the course of time but
until we have agronomically safe uh
Alternatives we we will not be able to
adopt these measures we must continue
with IPM therefore we have presented a
um Amendment 685 signed by four
political groups that sets the time at
2035 for implementation of this we need
to have the time so that we can have the
effective Alternatives therefore what we
saw from the commission's proposal for
the percentage of reduction for member
states there were a number of different
problems for from the member states as
you know that we therefore we come up
with Amendment 686 with a 35% reduction
Target by the member states now it is
extremely important as well when it
comes to the reduction of plant
production products in sensitive areas
it depends on the area that we are
looking at uh 687 the amendment divides
this in two and states where there are
major farming surface areas we
categories one and two in biocontrol and
organic farming applies and I would like
to state that the capap cannot be used
for everything and certainly not for a
drastic reduction that would be used for
all of the standards that are going to
be um passed in article 343 we deleted
that also we need to make sure that we
have enough food supply our proposal M
maintains that this will be the case
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much indeed and now for the
commission commissioner Stella kir aides
you have the
floor what Madam president honorable
Members First of all I want to thank you
for the opportunity to debate the
commission proposal for a regulation on
the sustainable use of plant protection
products now ever since the commission
has adopted this proposal in June
2022 it has been the subject of strong
and passionate debate both Among The
Honorable members in this house and also
in the widest stakeholder
community and this is entirely
understandable because the use of
pesticides is both an important and a
sensitive
topic our previous discussions made
clear that we can at least agree on one
basic principle namely the importance of
protecting citizens health and the
environment at the same time protecting
the eu's farm Farmers agricultural
production and food
security and because we agree on this
principle I believe it is possible to
reconcile the differing views and to
make constructive progress on this
file constructive progress that will on
the one hand respond to the demands from
the citizens and consumers to reduce the
ruse and risk of pesticides but at the
other on the other hand simultaneously
ensure that our Farmers retain an
effective Pest Control toolbox and
sufficient alternatives to the use of
chemical
pesticides I note the emphasis placed on
setting a positive Target for the use of
biocont control and low-risk
products the commission and I wanted to
to share this with you is working
intensively with member states industry
and stakeholders to promote the
availability and use of biocont control
and lowrisk alternatives to chemical
pesticides our nonp paper on sensitive
areas highlighted numerous ways in which
the use and risk of pesticides could be
reduced in such areas and still protect
our
agriculture we also provided a
comprehensive complimentary analysis
after the proposal had been adopted at
the council's request in our response
we emphasize how progress towards the
pesticide reduction targets could be
made without compromising our food
security and how the administrative
burden on small and medium scale farmers
can be reduced and
minimized now turning to the
international aspects we must not lose
sight of the goals agreed at cop 15
Global biodiversity framework meeting in
Montreal last December one such intern
National agreed Target focuses on the
overall risk from pesticides by at least
half by 2030 included through integrated
Pest Management and taking into account
food security and
livelihoods this target comes close with
the ambition set out in the commission's
SE
proposal president honorable members I
have always believed that it is of
utmost importance that all views on this
topic are listened to both carefully and
respectfully the commission has been
doing that for the last 18 months we
have been showing pragmatism and
flexibility and I maintain that belief
because I think it's the last our best
chance at achieving progress I'm going
to be hearing all the points raised in
this debate very carefully I hope that
they can be brought forward in the
trialogue discussion that will follow
once Council agrees on its General
approach on this file once again thank
you for all your constructive
discussions with this I look forward to
the debate thank
you thank you very much indeed uh
commissioner and now micheli will
present the opinion of the committee on
development mer
thank you Madame
President thank you
commissioner I know you're interested in
arguments I have scientific and
political
arguments first of all this is one of
the most important pieces of legislation
of this parliamentary term this Su
regulation and I want to congratulate
Sarah vinaa for the tremendous work that
she and her co-rapporteur have
done there are two very important things
in this world safeguarding biodiversity
and we know that biodiversity is at risk
from pesticides all the science shows
the effect of pesticides on flora and
FAA there are pesticides in water in the
air and throughout the environment and
then there's
Health just
a couple of days ago
Monsanto uh had was presented with uh
evidence linking monsanto's pesticides
with
cancer if you consider uh Farmers uh
health and the occupational diseases
suffered by Farmers clearly pesticides
have a role to play it's it's very
important
for uh us politicians to gain the upper
hand over the Agri food Lobby we should
be demonstrating to our voters that
Europe protects
them unfortunately if we don't do that
the lobby will have won this s
regulation is of huge importance I
should kindly ask you to stick to your
speaking
times
and now speakers on behalf of political
groups starting with the EP and
Alexander
bhba Madam president Madam
commissioner in kindergarten uh we are
taught not to play with our food but
what is of concern here is um the the
way that we're playing with our food
security we need to understand the role
of plant protection
products it's a tool for Farmers to be
able to provide food security and to
provide us with food on a daily basis I
think it's very sad that we're talking
about reference years reduction targets
without really taking a view of the
whole what our Farmers need is quicker
access to alternative plant protection
products and finding those Alternatives
and there are more than one unacceptable
points in your report Miss
Vina prohibiting all ppps in sensitive
areas for example and that would affect
many areas in Austria that we greatly
value in your proposal it would be
almost impossible to carry out
sustainable development here and it
would be those who are carrying out the
best work who would be penalized I'm
also disappointed by the
commission
we're looking at the last remnants of Mr
timberman's works because if a proposal
has to be changed time and again it
can't really be a basis for the
discussion we all
want however we have the opportunity
here to vote for a
reasonable vote for reasonable
legislation that sets the framework for
the next 10 20 years and guarantee food
security but I think we can only do that
if we uh join together uh with farmers
and demonstrate that we at the European
Parliament can find a broad majority for
a reasonable solution that we can solve
problems with with one another not
against one another thank
[Applause]
you thank you Mr bher now on behalf of
the snd group Maria Arena thank you very
much Madame President eurobarometer
shows us that European citizens are
ready and requesting a more sustainable
world without pesticides these are Stark
St statistics but I could also tell you
about the impact on biodiversity on bees
but I should rather talk to you about
the citizens all of you here in this
hemicycle you represent these citizens
and they are requesting accountability
and quickly I'd like to talk to you
about a farmer throughout the course of
his career he used pesticides on his
fruit trees a few days prior to his
retirement he was diagnosed with
prostate cancer and now must fight for
the remain his remaining days physical
and mental shocks but even more he
laments the lack of information by
manufacturers and the lack of protection
equipment apparently the protection
equipment was worse for his health than
without I'd like to talk to about
someone who
manages a an equestrian facility using
her herbicides in his activity this time
it is his son prior to birth was exposed
in the womb to these products at 16
years of age
following um Mal formations has already
had 54 operations these are broken lives
because of pesticides and we have to add
to this the ecological disaster these
are reasons why we must act now I can
also understand the farmers that are
making requests the overwhelming
majority want to be able to produce
better and not be prisoners to Big
chemical uh a uh companies M vay's
report I'd like to thank her is the best
balance here in this European Parliament
it answers the urgency asking for a
binding reduction Target and the use of
these pesticides I should like to call
on you to reject the agre Amendments and
from the agre committee these amendments
will not meet our objectives that we are
seeking now I understand ladies and
gentlemen that many of you are under the
pressure of agre associations but let us
be conscious of the fact that the
elections are coming up it's not the
farmers who are going to vote it's the
citizens who are calling on all of us to
be responsible thank you
you thank you very much Miss Arena and
now for the renew Europe group Yan
H thank you very much Madame President
commissioner honorable
members I'm not aware of
anybody not wanting to reduce pesticide
use and that includes Farmers it's very
important to make sure we reduce the
risks emanating from pesticides this is
in the interests of farmers and the
environment
alike it
is a clearly a
waste if we use too many uh substances
in order to produce a good harvest and
then find out in September that we don't
have uh much of a
harvest if we want to reduce pesticide
use it's important for Farmers to have
Alternatives with which they can protect
their
products and I'm not thinking in terms
of uh genetically modified uh substances
unfortunately the uh modern alternative
atives are not yet easily
accessible there is an issue with
permitting and there is an issue with
sensitive
areas in the field of medicines
permitting and authorization seems to
work very fast in the field of plant
protection products that is not
unfortunately the
case
thank
you and now Martin heising on behalf of
the greens European free
Alliance colleagues tomorrow we can
accept this proposal and send a strong
message because it's about protecting
biodiversity and protecting health of
European
citizens and that is very much part of
uh this approach we need a different
model of Agriculture with different uh
approach to pesticides fewer pesticides
um we need to work in areas where we is
possible to use zero or very little
pesticides what's absolutely clear is
that if we um
pursue integrated
um agriculture uh then we can save uh
the use of about a third of pesticides
and obviously protected areas need to be
free from pesticides in order to protect
nature we need to send a clear message
to European citizens saying that we take
the protection of biodiversity seriously
commissioner if the commission if the
commission sends the wrong signal and
allows pesticides for glyphosate for a
further 10 years um then that would be
the wrong message we need to take
glyphosate off the
[Applause]
market thank you Mr heising
the next speaker is Mr vondra of the ECR
group but I don't see him in the chamber
and I therefore call
Sylvia Limer who represents the ID
group
preses president miss KES The Proposal
from the commission on the use of plant
protection is would be catastrophic not
just for German fire but also for the
scale of its impact for Europe um we
have innumerable regulations which would
further burden those who are already
struggling and also sweeping bands uh
which would for example in North vest
failure affect 90% of agricultural
territory um this is in addition to huge
numbers of rules which
well trained Farmers U see has a huge
problem and it would push them over the
edge in many cases it would be the end
of many farms so that's why I call on my
German colleagues from the CDU CSU but
also on the entire EP political group
please vote for our motion to reject if
you don't want to be part of uh this
agreen bandwagon and
the fork Farm strategy has led
to many negative consequences as a
result of your votes in the past so it's
a time to show that you care about our
farmers and our food security and that
you can put those above your party
ideology um M
Vina you see food as if it were full of
poison thank to you a large part of our
food in the future would come from
States outside the EU food of dubious
origin thank you very
much thank you the next speaker is Ana
hakum thank you very much Madame
President to
commissioner bees butterflies and birds
are under threat of
Extinction farmers and their neighbors
are increasingly ill with Parkinson's
cancer other
diseases drinking water is ever more
expensive biodiversity is shrinking
across the
world the common denominator here is the
use of agricultural poisons and this
must stop millions of citizens and very
many uh scientists and the party for the
animals are calling for poison-free
agriculture calling for food to be
produced in a different
way in harmony with nature instead of
strangling nature
it's important to switch to
sustainable
agriculture supermarkets should be
paying an honest price for poison free
food we would also be helping to make
life livable in the countryside thank
you
thank you m Hamp M Hamp who was speaking
on behalf of the left group and now on
behalf of the non-attached members Maria
Dani thank you very much president thank
you commissioner protecting public
health is something that obviously goes
through food
security sustainable use of pesticides
is therefore fundamental to contain any
impact
on human health the environment and
Animal Health it's one health approach
the commission's proposal and is an
excellent starting point however we
cannot forget that the quality of our
products depends very much on training
and support that we give to our Farmers
we must assist them in embracing this
transition incentivize research in terms
of farming systems without the use of
pesticides and first and foremost
increase controls on the markets
reducing the use of pesticides and
import of any product from third
countries we must fight unfair
competition we can do more let us reform
the capap and put small farmers at the
core control on products that means that
we need to invest in a future and
quality in farms the benefits will be
great and for all thank
[Applause]
you thank you Miss Dani and the next uh
speaker is Alexander vondra for the ECR
group stuck in the traffic
so ladies and
gentlemen I'll put it
bluntly the report prepared by Sarah
vinaa is is a bad report it penalizes
member states that for years have been
reducing pesticide
use it makes it impossible for them to
Define sensitive
areas where there will be restrictions
on pesticide
use the aim is to Define uh these on a
paneuropean basis rather than taking
local conditions into account there is
nothing but orders and prohibitions in
here there's no room for discussion we
know we know what the left think about
new
methods our Farmers though deserve less
green fanaticism and more realism not
for the sake of farming alone but for
the sake of consumers
ill-considered
regulation is going to lead to higher
prices and if the Agri amendments don't
get through we will not be supporting
this
proposal VRA thank you Mr
VRA the next speaker is France
bogovic
thank you in the EP many of us support a
reduction in pesticide
use and there has been a 33% reduction
over the past 5 years this is uh this is
a good thing and a further reduction by
50 of 50% by 2030 is a a good
plan in some countries there's less of a
need for pesticides and you could
actually uh reduce even further but I
also appreciate the role given to member
states in defining sensitive areas it's
no business of the European Union to
decide where uh there are sensitive
areas in Slovenia or Austria the fact is
sometimes there are orchards in these
sensitive
areas
whatever happens is we have to maintain
food Security in the interest of
Europe's citizens we need to respect the
environment and I think that these
proposals will
help thank you Mr bogovic the next
speaker is Muhammad
shahim thank you very much uh we
see wide use of pesticides and that
constitutes a threat to our environment
our
health we see very serious illnesses
caused uh by
pesticides um the problem of phyto
pharmaceutical products is something
that we should address together um there
is an alternative there are alternative
products but they need licenses being
granted more
rapidly um for example biological active
agents which can be of great use to
European Farmers uh we need to ensure
however that such agents are used more
broadly than they are used at the
moment that will enhance crops uh
enhance quality
protect the environment protect public
health and allow me just to recall allow
me to recall
the commission comes with proposals we
have Madame kirak here or V address them
please and not someone who's not in the
room thank you very
[Applause]
much thank you very much and the next
speaker is Emma
V thank you very
much when it comes to a reduction in
pesticide use this must be done in a
very careful and precise
way now we're not looking just at
pesticides but also the use of
antibiotics and it's good to be first in
line in terms of these measures but we
shouldn't lose
competitiveness in terms of
cost and we this shouldn't lead to an
increase in Imports with a lower
standards now we know that there are
exemptions for some
countries but have to set standards and
make sure that other countries are
meeting those standards that is what
Sweden has done we shouldn't have
a negative impact on
competitiveness so making sure that we
are focusing on that for Swedish Farmers
as well thank you for
so
thank
you now you mentioned the exemp the
exemption
this has a high objective
for reduction for European Farmers now
we know that there are binding
objectives
here one thing is extremely
clear
we know that there will be a price to
pay even if this has an impact on
Farm thank you very much
missadel um we're talking about
competitiveness
here we know that this will bring to a
reduction in y in uh pesticide use we've
seen that in Sweden that means that
other European countries must do the
same thing what the Swedish Farmers have
already
done it's extremely good for our farming
system the competitiveness thereof but
we know that there were costs in this
reduction and it's unfortunate that
there hasn't been support for this
proposal that will uh definitely have an
impact on the
competitiveness the next speaker is
Claude grer you have the floor
pres Madame President commissioner
colleagues tomorrow when you vote on the
misnamed uh sustainable use of plant
protection products I suggest that you
vote on the basis of your conscience
there is a European uh citizens
initiative to save bees and save Farmers
that calls on us to abandon or reduce
the use of
pesticides if that's not enough then
think about the fact that pesticides are
the main cause of water pollution the
main cause of um biodiversity reduction
if that's still not enough think about
our Farmers think about our farmers who
are first in line as victims of these
chemical
products
unfortunately there is no protection
from prostate cancer Parkinson's disease
leukemia this is a major public health
Scourge and there's no way we can
help what we have to do is to stop these
chemicals destroying lives destroying
families it is time to
help the victims and their carers are
watching us I want to thank Sarina for
her
work thank you Ma is the next
speaker president
commissioner agricultural sustainability
is crucial for ensuring our food
sovereignty and the survival of farmers
there's nobody better than them to
protect the environment but who is
protecting them the farmers are
constantly facing economic difficulties
and significant losses of their crops
and what do we do we simply throw
further obstacles at them um for example
reducing plant protection products which
are really play a role as medicines for
plants we don't take into account that
this reduction could have a huge impact
on their yields and that's not
reasonable the behavior and attitudes of
so-called ecologists put the survival of
farmers and food security at threat the
major Paradox here is the same time
we're opening up our borders to products
from third countries which are far from
meeting the requirements that we expect
from our own food producers we need to
develop strategies for sustainable use
yes but without jeopardizing Farmers
capacity to protect their own
livelihoods and the protection of food
which is necessary for society thank
you thank you m agil and now mat
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions as is this regulation it is
laudable to want to reduce pesticide use
but there are scientific and social
problems
attendant
the European Commissioners are proposing
a regulation to reduce pesticide use by
50% uh by 2030 for no particular reason
without justification this 50% cut is
based on average consumption in 2011
2013 in 2011 pesticide use increased
this is not going to work without
creating enormous problems especially
for farmers who are already
suffering as a result of your standards
unfortunately there are no uh not
sufficient Alternatives there's also the
question of
uh implementation what about these
exceptions for tea and coffee uh what is
the point of creating a Soviet farming
Market why are we listening to these Eco
lobbies who have no scientific evidence
behind what they're
proposing thank you the next speaker is
Sandra
per thank you very much president the
unstainable use of pesticides is having
a huge impact on our Public Health on
our environment and on our food and
indeed we can see that this has a huge
impact on our farming we must have the
precautionary approach in terms of the
nefarious impact of these pesticides on
our workers and on our people we have to
make sure that we have a productive
system that goes hand inand with
Environmental Protection and with the
protection
ofm in the farming sector the
sustainable use of uh plant protection
product products is focused on a
monocrop approach and this shows that we
need to have a completely different
development model based on national
production and food
sovereignty promoting more
environmentally
friendly measures for our farming is
important to make sure that our farming
does not our farming sector does not
disappear making sure that we use
indigenous approaches and at at the same
time protecting our better and closer
Public Services ones that work for the
citizens thank
you thank you m Pereira the next speaker
is
Ed president it's a major challenge that
we have recently started to address
um
the left seem to be focusing on
worsening an already serious situation
it is time to um look at our
conventional methods and through those
guarantee food security because of the
war because of uh Co because of changing
weather we are already seeing an
accumulation of Crisis if food
production volumes drop prices will rise
even further and that's not something
that we can tolerate and the European
people won't be in a position to pay for
food we need to find a
compromise striking a balance between
ecological and economic concerns thank
you thank you Mr to the next speaker is
p petera colle and colleague
colleagues as a doctor and environmental
specialist I'm in favor of cautious use
of plant protection products and I'm in
favor of reduction but I'm against this
proposal in many cases this proposal
bans the use of chemical
products and it uses a definition of
sensitive areas which in My Views is in
my view is uh
inappropriate believe it or not in my
constituency the uh environmentalists
are on my
side they are saying it is wrong to
jeopardize the good cooperation that
exists between environmentalists and
I'm particularly in favor of amendment
487 Miss Aguilera please
listen as as agre rapporter it's your
duty to fight for that Amendment thank
you thank you P lead to the next speaker
Maria
colleagues I think that uh we should
make our decisions in a democracy based
on facts we know and these are the facts
that the Intensive use of pesticides
leads
to a reduction in
biodiversity and the extinction of
species in protected areas there was a
drop of over
75% of insect Mass we know that
pesticides lead to leukemia Parkinson
disease higher probability of cancers U
diabetes um we know and these are
fact that the EU has a an approach to
authorization filled with Lo loopholes
there's no extensive research into the
cocktail effect on the effect of uh on
on soil Health there are millions of
organisms which have not been tested for
for their for the impact on them of
pesticides we know that the industry has
held back research showing detrimental
effects and I am in favor of stronger
regulation of pesticides and therefore
we'll vote accordingly thank
you thank you m n the next speaker is
ELC kattin thank you Madame President
commissioner
reducing the use of plant protection
products is uh is right to do at EU
level but it has to be done in a
balanced way and we have to take Farmers
with us unfortunately the commission
proposal didn't take them into account
but now uh the uh environment
committee's position has been improved
I'd like to thank the rapporter but
there's more to do it's right to
recognize uh local conditions for
example when defining sensitive areas in
addition
uh moving the uh Target by 5 years to
2035 gives the sector more time to bring
new products to Market which can replace
the chemicals currently used to provide
us with food Farmers need to have the
tools to do their job finally this
legislation must not lead to a situation
where uh member states which
historically have reduced pesticides use
for example like Finland have to reduce
even further instead the legislation
should focus on those areas those
countries where pesticide use is above
the EU average thank
you thank you m Gard the next speaker is
TI
Mets dear commissioner dear president
first of all congratulations to the
green reporter Sarina for her tireless
work on this file sustainable use of
pesticide when when it comes to chemical
pesticide isn't that a bit of a
contradiction when it comes to our
health BYOD diversity and the health of
our ecosystem the less pesticides the
better which is why we needed to
increase the ambition of The
commission's Proposal especially when it
comes to reduction targets but today one
of the most harmful pesticide is likely
to be on the market for another 10 years
yes I'm speaking about glyphosate which
the commission plans to reauthorize
because member states failed to ban it
and glyphosate is but one dangerous
pesticide still used today so when we
vote on what sensitive Irish are and
what can be sprayed in and around and
please don't think of the short-term
profit of big companies but think of the
people and the children that will be
exposed to this pesticide I don't want
to have to tell the future generation
that we fail them by failing to embrace
less toxic ways of managing past and
producing foods thank
[Applause]
you thank you Miss Mets and the next
speaker
is beran
Rison thank you colleagues with regard
to the reduction of plant protection
products I see that the situation is
evolving in agriculture with using
greater natural elements in um certain
areas or we using um specific
Alternatives so there's work to be done
the objective of 50% reduction by
2030 um is extremely risky does it leave
us with enough Headroom to fight against
um plant diseases and pests I would
think not and there's also the
definition of sensitive areas it um
creates issues because it would lead to
a total ban on plant protection products
in uh key areas of Europe with an impact
on food production what we need is a new
approach a different approach not rigid
inflexible targets no we need support
for the sector's own initiatives which
certainly can reduce impact on the
environment I'm thinking about Precision
agriculture or the use of low risk
inputs thank
you thank you Mr R now
Ros echology
ideology here we have ideology the
majority of this Parliament put forth
ideology when it came up with dramatic
reductions in plant production products
in fact the proposals are more
restrictive than what the commission had
prop
proposed dogmatism and
perhaps they will realize it when the
entire sector is at its knees or perhaps
that's the objective I think we should
State this clearly these stringent
Norms go towards
environmental interests but without
looking at the production or food
Security in fact all of Europe will be
exposed to problems with food security
and we are looking to destroy European
farming because dear colleagues our
farmers do not need free advisory
services on preventive measures what
they need is to be able to use the
instruments that they need to be able to
work considering the fact that they
don't have any valid Alternatives at
this time thank
you thank you Miss con and now
Karina thank you very much Madam
president colleagues all of us want good
safe food and we need plant protection
products this is part of the eu's food
security the use of pesticides is not
bad but reducing it across the board by
a half is wrong there are differences
between member states of the EU for
example Slovakia you has a very low
pesticide use compared with West
European intensive agriculture I
therefore cannot support
the um targets of 50%
reduction and uh a reduction to zero in
certain areas this will break slow back
farming and Forestry colleagues I don't
think we're going to agree but I think
we do all agree we should have less
fanaticism and more realism in this
chamber we have to grow food because
people need to eat and we have to
protect our
crops and I think that what we should be
doing is looking for Alternatives we
should be looking at uh uh bio control
and we should be looking at Banning
monocultures and more support for
Farmers of course thank
you
thank you the next speaker is har
dman fewer chemicals uh in farming fewer
pesticides that's a good thing it's in
the interest of everybody it's in the
interest of farmers it will reduce their
costs some people in this house are a
bit
simplistic uh Farmers don't grow crops
just because they feel it they feel like
it they have to grow their crops they
have to protect their uh crops from
pests it's all about safeguarding the
Harvest and Farmers income of course
there can be a reduction and we need uh
incentives to Industry for research and
development to develop new methods so
that farmers have a real alternative in
the agriculture committee most groups
have worked well together and we have
good compromises as a result that takes
both things into account the uh desire
to reduce plant protection product use
and the desire of farmers to protect
their products and I think we should
Vote for This agre committee compromis
tomorrow thank
you thank you Mr Dorfman the next
speaker is Kristoff
CL Madame commissioner colleagues the
general debate on pesticides is
interesting but the specific debate on
glyphosate is all the more so now I was
very surprised over the course of recent
weeks that the commission's proposal
never
changes the member states positions have
never been factored in nor have the
positions of uh parliamentarians or
stakeholders it seems that it's
obstinate blind and I'd like to call on
all members of this Parliament to um
sign on to the case on secret parti
that's going before the ecj now we know
that there's uncertainty and scientific
controver controversy epsa said before
this Parliament that the means to assess
the risk of pesticides were not enough
and that they weren't able to work
correctly 80% of scientific Publications
are thrown out uh based on the databases
of epsa for risk assessment now let us
make sure that this is based on science
you didn't even take into account
epa's uh opinion you just threw it back
to the member states in terms of the uh
value assessment of risk and protecting
Public Health thank
you thank you Mr CL the next speaker is
Asar Christensen you have the
floor thank you president the
commission's first proposal to pesti
sest pesti side legislation was
completely wide of the mark and it could
have shut down the entire Danish plant
production in so-called sensitive areas
of course uh we must reduce the use of
pesticides we've done that um by half
since
2011 uh Danish farmers will use uh
pesticide with new technology but there
needs to be a reward uh for such
reduction we need to put the carrot
rather before the stick um and focus on
what is
absolutely useful we have uh good
targets for 2035 that's a good date and
of course we need to include crisper
technology um that will help us in this
area uh Precision agriculture is
something that will drive development U
but um we need to improve the approval
processes of biop pesticides um before
we can actually phase without existing
pesticides we can't go too slowly thank
you very
much thank you Mr Christensen the next
speaker is UT
paos thank you Madame President
commissioner
colleagues it is very interesting to
hear people talking about their
countries being in the Vanguard of
reducing pesticide use and and therefore
this regulation not being necessary
let's come back to the scientific facts
though the European environment agency
has published report after report
demonstrating that
biodiversity is under threat and
biodiversity is not a value in itself it
is the basis on which we survive through
drinking water clean water clean air
fertile land the environment
agency has demonstrated that farming is
behind the the use of pesticides in the
EU the environment committee has drafted
a very good report in support of farmers
who will get financial support
independent advice and it's very
interesting to hear from the agriculture
committee saying that they want to uh
deny Farmers this financial support and
quite clearly uh farmers are not uh
endangering their health just for the
hell of it and we really want to support
them through this a blue card for
you would you accept a blue card from uh
uh
Mr Ben
Huber go ahead so half a minute Mr Ben
hobber and then half a minute from Mr
pus thank you very much miss paulos you
talked about protecting nature in Europe
but even and the European commission is
saying that we will be dependent on
Imports in
future the Sara Vina report uh
demonstrates that we will have more uh
Imports and don't you see a
contradiction because you want Europe to
be green and yet we're going to be
importing from third
countries the European
Commission
is basing itself on the fact that we're
going to be throwing a third of food
away and that we're that there are going
to be whole areas where we're not
growing food at all I think that would
make I think it would more make more
sense to do something about that than to
be thinking about
Imports the EP is usually voting against
uh my proposals
regarding uh limits Mrs paros another
blue card from Peter Li and um would you
accept this blue card I'm sure you
accept it so Peter Lea have a minute and
then back to UTA
Palos
yeah thank
you you wanted to stick with the facts
The Proposal is officially about plant
protection products if we could agree on
the terminology the terminology is plant
protection products and not pesticides
and do you think that the new
cultivation methods constitute a means
of reducing plant protection products
and will you join us in supporting these
new cultivation
methods
plants plant protection product is
indeed uh misleading especially in the
case of herbicides which kill plants so
plant protection products is um
strange we should perhaps be talking
about crop protection products maybe if
we agree on pesticides which is
established in science on the uh new
cultivation methods I'm not sure we'll
actually get to a reduction of
pesticides and I don't know if farmers
are that happy about the new uh
cultivation uh methods with uh patented
seeds for
example no more blue cards for you Mrs
now it got a little Lively
good and now back to the speaker's list
and the next speaker is Kristoff yurel
you have the
floor Madam president I'm in favor of
rejecting the uh proposal in its
entirety we should not be voting for
legislation which conflicts with the
interest of our Farmers I have always
been critical of this draft
regulation the uh polish Agriculture and
Forestry sector is uh very much under
threat there are uh politically
motivated aspects to this uh
legislation uh and I'm particularly
critical of the sensitive areas which
have been defined in such a way that in
some member states they actually make up
most of the cultivated territory the
methodology uh behind the uh reduction
in use is highly uh
problematic there is a percentage
reduction which is applied across the
board and that is
wrong thank you Mr
yurel and the next speaker is Jessica
Pia thank you very much president
commissioner
colleagues European
Farmers need to be able to have a medium
and long-term perspective and be
guaranteed that they can use pesticides
in a responsible way in a safe way if
when
necessary it's simply not possible for
us to state that we should find a way to
increase food production in Europe and
then have a proposal at the same time
that could hit our producers hard many
countries in Europe have already reduced
the uh amount of pesticides in use
therefore we should give more influence
to the member states in terms of the
definition for example of protected
areas no proposals should re-evaluate
the agricultural sector we need to take
this time to look at farming not as a
problem but as a part of the solution
Thank
You From
Emma blue card from Emma visner so so
Emma very good half a minute for Emma
visner thank
you now here we are being traders to the
Swedish
Farmers they have reduced their
pesticide
use and there are requirements these
need to be factored in what we need to
do now is to make sure that this
proposal means that other
member states do the same that that what
the Swedish Farmers have already
done to show them uh the responsibility
that they have taken because we have to
be able to strengthen the
competitiveness of our Farmers most
thank you very much for this I do
believe that we must find a way to make
sure that Nordic countries that have
already reduced their pesticide use
are factored in fully for what they have
done it's the farmers who are saying
this that they are struggling very much
to meet the objectives that the European
Parliament is setting in this way
therefore they are stating that it's
going to be hard for them to produce
effectively and efficiently it's not
just a problem for Swedish
Farmers thank you back to the speaker's
list and the next speaker is Pao deastro
colleagues without the active
participation of our Farmers any type of
action to uh mitigate climate change
will be unrealistic therefore in our
agre committee and our uh rapporter M
aguiler and I'd like to thank her has
tried to find the best possible balance
an ambition one so sustainability as we
have undertaken to do but as the
European Union but also the needs of our
Farmers to make sure that our farmers
are assisted in this transition now the
work that we carried out has moved
Beyond ideological positions and has
moved to pragmatic result results making
the objective realistic to reduce by 50%
in our plant protection products but we
need to have Innovation to make sure
that we can uh fight these uh pests with
the new bio sustainable bio techniques
colleagues tomorrow we have a vote let
us leave behind polarization to come up
with a text that really does support
environmental so social and economic
sustainability in our farming sector but
also in our rural areas thank
you thank you very much Mr dcastro and
the next speaker is Andreas
cluk
president uh colleagues a genuine
strategy for reduction yes but sweeping
bands no we're looking at multiple
crises in the world so safe and secure
food security and production in the EU
is essential it's not an alternative
simply to increase the burden on our
farmers and reduce our yields which
would just mean we need to buy more on
the World
Market when it comes to buy diversity I
have to say frankly that we cannot FOC
on restrictions again and again and Lead
when we're seeing greater world hunger
from the commission and from the
parliament we need to point the way not
just simply introduce
bands sensitive area prohibitions is
something that I would
refuse it would be particularly harmful
for rural areas it would throttle the
agricultural culture and lead to the the
opposite of what the intention is yes
there should be limits but only if um it
has a
use and it needs to be of value to these
protected sensitive areas thank
[Applause]
you
um I think the rapporter wants the blue
card to you Mr
GLI would you accept the blue card from
the rapporter SAR Viner of course thank
you sarer half a
minute Lia and
GL Mr Gluk you're talking about uh 100%
bans but what about the um exception in
sensitive areas that member states um
would allow pesticides in all areas why
are you talking about total banss when
they simply don't exist
well M Vina I think um we need to
proceed uh together in Europe on this we
can't simply throw up different
situations in member states we need to
start from a principled base and I think
there's a reversal of the burden of
proof where plant protection
product um use is compromised where
they're not achieving the protection
that they're designed for yes I believe
that there should be limitations but to
start with a ban um is not the right way
around I think first of all you should
allow and then ban when necessary thank
you thank you Mr Gluk the next speaker
is Anna Deane
grunenberg Madam president uh ladies and
gentlemen
more than a half of uh field birds are
are no longer there pesticides are at
fault pesticides don't stay in the
fields the rain washes them into the
streams and they become part of our
drinking water via the rivers and water
courses
um
finches blackbirds
thrushes are these going to be just a
historical memory in
future chemical pesticides should be
seen as a last
resort we have to be able to stop this
destruction of our farming sector we
need a radical reduction in pesticide
use and I call on you to vote for a
strong SE
and with your help through showing
responsibility we will have a strong
farming sector into the future Gren
thank you Anna Deane grunenberg and now
the chair of the agriculture committee
Nobert
Lin president uh colleagues during the
pandemic and the context of the attack
on Ukraine by Russia we became aware of
just how important it is to ensure that
Europe can provide itself with high
quality food and this is also a
principle that we need to bear in mind
alongside the issue of climate climate
protection and biodiversity when it
comes to making the vote tomorrow I
believe that the proposal of the
Agricultural committee on reductions is
the necessary approach deferring to to
2050 and the idea of protected areas
sensitive areas and uh bans and
prohibitions needs to be considered the
suggestion of the environmental
committee
um is not the right approach we need to
avoid penalizing those areas that have
already contributed a great deal
and where I live uh we have the latest
Cutting Edge in Ecom monitoring we are
cooperating with Farmers not confronting
them uh not opposing them and that's the
questions that we need to answer at the
vote tomorrow thank
you um I think the rapporter wants to
present the blue card is that correct we
don't have the sign here you had to
press the
button just a
second uh Mr lince do you accept the
blue card okay sarer half a minute
um
yeah Mr Lind you're talking about
protected areas that they should exist
can you tell me quickly um H how you
will protect such sensitive areas from
the detrimental effect of pesticides
where are they and how would you protect
them
well remember Vina it's a question of
reversing the burden of proof we need to
clarify that there is a threat to
certain species from a specific product
and not start from the other end with
Comprehensive
bands and the exceptions decided upon by
member states should depoliticize uh
these issues member states with a number
of protected and sensitive areas
including my home country Germany uh
every six Hector is affected by uh such
u rules so we need to
have a practical approach and bear in
mind the advocacy for farmers in these
areas thank
you thank you the next speaker is G
zedel Madam president commissioner we
all know that uh whatever we release
into nature eventually ends up in our
bodies this report is a key
uh aspect of the green
deal we're in a situation
where uh the four big seed manufacturers
control 2/3 of the pesticide Market this
level of concentration is wrong we have
to reduce our dependence we need
alternatives to glyphosate and so on
that requires a European effort for a
research effort into an effective
alternative to pesticide use this is
absolutely vital for the future of
Europe's farming and food security
seedle there's a blue card for you would
you accept the blue card from Mr benher
yes Mr
benher thank
you tomorrow we're going to be voting on
the future use of plant protection
products in vaja will you be voting in
favor of the Veno report and uh the
blanket ban that it contains or will you
be voting in favor of one of the
Alternatives we need to reduce pesticide
use and that is a trend that cannot be
stopped as regards V this is a sensitive
subject and I think that the proposal as
a whole takes its interest into
account thank you Daniel Buddha is the
next
speaker thank you very much colleagues
war is an indisputable
reality hunger leads to migration and
food prices have risen to scarcely
affordable levels today's debate cannot
be divorced from this reality the
responsible use of pesticides has to be
a goal for all member states but
especially those whose consumption is
currently well above the EU average
there are countries which use more than
8 kilog per hectare but we also have
member states that have understood the
need for responsible use of pesticides
for example Romania which uses just 640
G gr per
hectare why is it that we're hearing the
most from members from the countries
which use the most pesticides it's time
for you to be reducing pesticide use a
blanket reduction percentage across the
board would not only be deeply immoral
but it would punish those countries
which have already acted responsibly and
bring the European farming sector to its
knees the result would be Bank bcy of
the sector closure of farms leaving the
EU dependent on food imports from third
countries and don't forget that already
now 33 million EU citizens can only
afford a hot meal once every three
days thank you the next speaker
isas thank you madam
president I'm sorry but I don't
understand how this piece of legislation
has reached us it is unjust towards
those countries which currently use
minimal quantities of plant protection
products in Estonia 780 gram are used
per hectare in Holland 8
kilogram whether you apply a 50 35 or
10% reduction in Estonia it is unjust
towards the Estonian farmer and uh and
our uh competitiveness would take a hit
the former commission vice president
Timberman is now back home he's met
Dutch farmers and he has agreed to um
take their interests in account I
therefore call upon our green friends to
vote against the Injustice that we're
seeing in this house thank
[Applause]
you thank you Mr teras and the next
speaker is Mr tho alare
thank you very much president
commissioner
well I thought we had learned our lesson
I thought after a pandemic and a war I
thought after an unprecedented drought
we had shifted our
positions but apparently the left of
this
hemicycle is poised to put an end to the
production in Europe and and in Spain
whatever the case may be so this
proposal and the amended version could
have an irreparable impact on our
European farming sector continuing to
impose arbitrary restrictions without
any impact assessment we will not allow
this to happen without the farmers
having some sort of an alternative to
protect their crops we will not allow
these limits to be a able to be enforced
only on European Farmers whilst other
products from third countries that are
farmed without any restrictions come
into our Market we have learned the
lesson and let us use our heads tomorrow
in our vote vote in favor of food
security for all Europeans thank
you thank you Mr alare and uh now we
have seven requests under the catch the
procedure
and I'm going to ground all
seven but do please in return keep to
your speaking time p is the
first what what I'm worried about is the
philosophy behind this um in farming we
talk about uh the need
to take an approach which is fact-based
um but also protecting of nature on the
left of the house you have to understand
that farmers are not our enemies they
provide our food the fundamental
question is do we want to force this
upon them or do we want to facilitate it
I want to facilitate it you want to
impose it and I think that's the wrong
path thank
you thank you Peter
y Isabel caral is
next thank you very much president
commissioner dear colleagues now today
we are stating because of science that
it is fundamental for us to put an end
to the use of pesticides in order to
protect the health of our farm fers but
also us and our
environment however we have to
understand that we're going to need
targets to meet these objectives we are
going to need to be able to look at the
types of substances but also in terms of
the cost that means that we will need a
legislative framework that is more
effective
simplified and that assists Us in bi
using bio control for example the
efficient implementation of
IPM that as in The Proposal of this
regulation this is absolutely timely it
is important for IPM to be applied
throughout the EU in a uniform
way and that should be updated with our
increase in scientific knowledge on the
subject thank
you thank you MC Wallace is next thanks
very much president the science is clear
that the climate and biodiversity crisis
are the biggest threats to Global SEC
food security there's not a single
serious scientist in Europe who would
argue that this new pesticides
regulation or the nature restoration law
would pose a risk to European food
security the main objective of The
Proposal is not to even ban pesticides
but to replace them with safe and
sustainable Alternatives yet some of the
right-wing groups in here have declared
that their intention is to kill the
pesticide regulation and that and they
have done their best to do the same with
the nature restoration law they want to
delete the national reduction targets
which would totally undermine the
chances of achieving the overall EU
Target and to delay the 2030 reduction
targets to
2035 they claim to be defending farmers
and food security but in reality they're
defending the interest of the big
chemical pesticide companies and
Industrial
[Applause]
farming thank you Mark jaella is next
um allowed me to address the question
question of pen P pesticides banned here
but exported to the world because a lot
of them uh banned in Europe are exported
outside Europe it's a shocking practice
and it's unethical if these products are
banned on the European market it's
because their use is harmful for human
health U and biodiversity as well as the
environment and what's not good here
isn't good
elsewhere and further that which we
consider to be toxic here is
lethal the products also that we then
import from these countries contain the
very toxins that we wanted to ban it's a
boomerang effect and who are the victims
the citizens so we need to ban the
export of banned
pesticides in all member states and
ensure that that is respected thank
you thank you Mr
tabella Sean Kelly is
next I think as a result of all the
legislation we have passed in this
mandate many farmers feel sometimes
under attack and certainly not
appreciated and that's a Pity because
many are making huge efforts to farm
sustainably and reduce their carbon
footprint for instance in Ireland The
Targets in the pesticides directive have
already been met Apartments have great
credit for that but on the broader front
I think what we really need to do is to
put more money and effort into research
so that there will be Alternatives in
place before we introduce bands to go
putting the for the horse is not the way
to do business and I if we we do it the
other way around then we will ensure the
farmers incomes are protected food
security is guaranteed and we won't be
importing from places that haven't the
same restrictions as we
have thank you very
much thank you Maria graini has the
floor Madam president commissioner
colleagues if farmers are listening to
this debate
they will hear that everything is
connected to everything else it's
interesting to hear those that want
extreme
prohibitions uh
are are those who are U using the
most
you in my country there the farming
Market is is being devastated for
example by imports from Ukraine uh
without phytosanitary
checks if why should we be using 300
gram per hectare in Romania when the
Dutch are allowed to use 4
kilog this is going to destroy Europe's
uh Agriculture and this is going to lead
to massive imports from outside Europe
of food full of uh pesticides I I think
that the citizens have a right to know
they have a right to to know that uh the
green extremists are going to destroy us
next speaker
Yas
Flor
k a excuse me colleague well we have a
micro problem so I will give you minute
again so but please switch a
micro it's
working thank you president colleagues
commissioner I agree we need to protect
biodiversity we need climate action but
when it comes to pesticide
use we have to take full cognizance of
the fact that we do not use them just
for fun when they
are used sometimes the yield increase
three-fold the use must be limited but
we must allow farmers to have
alternative
methods measures must be fair colleagues
have stated
that pesticide use in the
EU differs from country to
Country
there are some countries where for
example in Lithuania use is 10 times
lower than in others and so with the new
um genetic
uh procedures we can make our plants
more resistant and resilient to climate
change these techniques will mean that
we can protect our
biodiversity and now I'd like to ask to
take a floor for the commission
commissioner
kades please
commissioner thank you Mr President
honorable Members First of all I'd like
to thank you for this very fruitful uh
debate and Lively debate and of course
many points were raised and I listened
to them carefully there's just one or
two points that I feel that I need to to
touch on um first of all it was said um
by an honorable speaker that we have not
listened to anyone I think the words
were used in relation to glyphosate and
I just want to say that this is not the
case we have had extensive
consultations um and taken in all
scientific opinions and with epsa and
with the European Capital Agency and
with stakeholders and of course we'll
continue to to listen there was also
several speakers mentioned the the issue
to do with the access that farmers could
have to um alternatives to chemical
pesticides and uh in the proposal there
are um numerous measures which are
intended to incentivize the use of
lowrisk and bi control substances and we
are already working with member states
and Industry and stakeholders to further
accelerate the transition and this is
outlined in the commission's response to
the article 24 uh 1 uh Council decision
and possibly some of these legislative
actions uh that co-legislators could
consider in the context of the SE
negotiations are uh for example allowing
provisional authorizations at member
state level for bi control products uh
or allowing unlimited approvals at EU
level for biocont control active
substances um and finally in the
comments that I heard coming up several
times that there is um a total ban uh in
the use uh in sensitive areas and in the
commission non paper there is no total
ban pesticides the use of on sensitive
areas the ban is only for the more H
hazardous
pesticides uh and what we are actually
uh advocating is the use of low-risk and
biocont control
products um so I will just like to say
here that uh uh as in many other files
that we find ourselves debating in this
plenary there are many different views
emphasis is placed in different ways but
these different views should not stop us
from making progress on this proposal
and I have many many times repeatedly
said that the commission is open to
potential solutions to finding workable
and effective compromises on the main
points of concern in the proposal and
once the council agrees in its uh
General approach i' very much look
forward to the interinstitutional
trialogue uh meetings because I believe
that they will allow us
to make uh progress on this file and
ultimately what we are trying to all
together do is meet the expectations of
citizens of consumers of farmers um and
of course of other pesticide users thank
you thank you commissioner Kiri aidis
now I would like to give a floor to
rapor SAR
Wier floor is yours as as you are here
so
thank you very much well that was an
exciting discussion and I'm left with
the questions raor whether some members
have actually read the sir
because there is no sweeping reduction
uh either for Farmers or for member
states um there is an
exception
um that is applied to your country for
example Mr Lisa you can repeat this
whole um idea of protecting um specific
countries but there is a paragraph for
regional reduction programs being
recognized by the
sir
we have um Extended the resources for um
Farmers to provide them with advice to
uh protect them from uh expensive
Imports and they need to understand what
needs to be done there we have
farmers who are part of society uh want
their environment to be protected
they're drinking water to be clean and
the future generations to be cared for
um so perhaps it's useful in the
campaign for an election to use these
sweeping statements that you've voiced
this morning but we need to look at the
detail of the and not to make these
sweeping statements and and try to scare
people we need to keep an eye on the
future move forward do what's good for
everybody because if it's good for
everybody for the environment for the
farmers for us for children then it's a
win-win situation and it's viable for
the future so we need a redu of
pesticides overall Target 50% by 2030 we
need to begin now if it's not achieved
then
the commission can change it what are
you afraid of let's work together uh
have a good vote on Sir tomorrow and not
try as the Agri committee has been doing
to keep everything um where it is and uh
simply lead us into the the desert I'm
convinced that uh together uh we can do
it I'd like to thank the shadow
reporters and members
and I am a farmer myself and what I want
is a viable country and a viable future
thank
[Applause]
you thank you colleagues therefore we
have concluded the debate on this point
of the agenda and vote will take place
tomorrow the next point on the agenda is
a report by boss Echo to strengthen the
CO2 emission performance targets for new
heavy duty vehicles and we'll now give
the floor to Mr eout
please thank you thank you Mr chairman
and thank you colleagues that was an
interesting debate on pesticides we now
shift to heavy duty vehicles trucks and
buses and also there we have some